-You were here in June 2017.
-Yeah.
-And I remember spending
the whole day
making sure I could say
your last name right.
And now you're so well-known,
it just rolls off my tongue.
-Yeah.
-Are you just as surprised
at the reaction you've gotten
in these early days
of sort of
announcing your candidacy?
-Yeah, just the speed of it.
I mean, obviously, we were
hoping for a good reaction.
We were hoping
for a good response.
But the way this thing
has taken off
has passed even our most
optimistic scenarios.
So now we've got a lot of work
to do to make sure we have
the organizing
and the substance behind it
to really take us all the way,
but it's a fantastic beginning.
-In the early days, before you
had name and face recognition,
were there humbling moments
when you were out
on the campaign trail?
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, not that long ago,
I was getting ready to board
a flight to New Hampshire.
A few people recognized me,
came up, said hello.
And then, the lady
standing right next to me said,
"You must be Pete."
And I was like, "Yeah."
She clearly
had seen these interactions.
And we had a nice little chat.
She said, "Why are you
going to New Hampshire?"
I said, "Well, 'cause of
the campaign, of course."
She said,
"Oh, right, right, right.
What station
are you a reporter for?"
[ Laughter ]
It was one of those moments
that cut me back down to size.
-Yeah.
-I forgot that not everybody
knows who I am.
But, you know, that's the thing
you gotta remember is,
you can feel like --
You can get into this bubble
and feel like everybody's
heard your message
when actually a lot of people
still haven't dialed in
for the process yet.
They're not following
the blow-by-blow.
And my job is to find as many
different ways as possible
to get the message out
to new people.
-I want to ask real quick,
before I get back
to your campaign
and your candidacy,
what was your initial reaction
to what we saw today
from Barr and the release
of the Mueller report?
-I mean, I guess it confirmed
a lot of things
that we were worried about,
that we have a president
who acts in a self-serving way,
that there was a lot of behavior
that was, at best, unethical
and legally problematic,
to put it charitably.
And, you know, the way that
the Attorney General
conducted himself, as though
he were the personal attorney
of the President,
was incredibly troubling, too.
At the same time,
I think, politically,
I'm not sure
it will change much.
And it's one more reminder
that if we really want
to send Trumpism
into the history books,
the best thing we can do
is defeat it decisively
at the ballot box in 2020.
-You have --
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're, uh...
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
I'm very good at, uh...
I'm very good at judging how the
audience feels about something.
They're split
right down the middle on this.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You have a military background.
One of the other things
that's been true, I think,
for the last two years
but especially sort of
upholding the focus today
is that Donald Trump
sort of always seems to want
to dismiss military intelligence
while at the same time
boasting about
what a great supporter
of the military he is.
Is that a hypocrisy that is --
do you feel more acutely
felt by you because of
your military background?
-Yeah, I mean, the thing that's
upsetting is when you're --
especially
in military intelligence,
when you're deployed,
like when I was in Afghanistan,
you do work believing --
You know, the highest honor,
really, that could happen to you
as a member of
the intelligence community
is that your work
goes to a policymaker
to help them make a decision.
You believe that they read
these things carefully.
And when people are putting
their lives on the line
in order to support
U.S. security
through good intelligence,
you know,
that whole system
rests on the belief
that the president,
the generals,
that they're using that infor--
or at least reading it, right?
But that they are
using it wisely.
To see the way that intelligence
is being politicized,
to see the way that military
families are being treated
as props by this president
is demoralizing.
And it's one more reason
why it might not be a bad idea
to have somebody in the
White House who actually served.
-You --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think there's this question,
and, obviously, in order to be
a successful
Democratic candidate,
you have
to bring together people
from many diverse backgrounds.
It's obviously
a more diverse voting base
than I think what you think of
as sort of a historically
Republican voting base.
Yet you -- So, when you
make a decision, like,
do you just commit
to the Democratic base?
Or when you make
an approach to Trump voters,
how do you speak to them?
What message is it that you,
or any of your colleagues
who are trying to get
this Democratic nomination,
approach Trump voters?
What's the message
you try to give?
-Well, look,
there are some voters
who we're never gonna
get through to.
But there are many others
that I think we can.
If somebody voted
repeatedly Democratic
and then voted
for this President,
out of any number of reasons,
but basically voted
to burn the house down,
I want that voter
back voting Democrat again.
And they're --
-'Cause they're sitting there
in a house that burned down,
and they're like, "Oh, no."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-"This was a terrible idea."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you know, to some extent,
it came from a level of
frustration around the system.
And that's not to excuse
the racism and other things
that went into that campaign.
But I think people are more
susceptible to those messages
of racism and xenophobia
if they also feel
a certain level
of insecurity or uncertainty
in their economic
and social lives.
And so what I think
we've got to do is,
we've got to reach out
to those voters,
reminding them that we're the
ones trying to get you a raise,
we're the ones trying to get
paid family leave,
we're the ones trying to stop
the Republican Congress
from taking away
your healthcare.
And while we do that --
and this is the important
thing alongside that -- we never
budge on our bedrock commitment
to racial and social justice.
'Cause that's where
our moral authority as a party
comes from in the first place.